learn how to make money with your
website from Anya Kubo Anya is an
excellent teacher and popular course
instructor and she will teach you some
different ways to monetize your website
hi everyone here on freecook I'm here
today to learn about web monetization
and theory and in practice
so first off what exactly is web
monetization and how would you explain
it to your friends in simple terms web
monetization means that you can get
money for every person that visits your
website sounds good right but how does
it work and who's paying for all this
these are the types of questions that we
will answer in this course
by the end of this crash course you will
know what web monetization is how to
implement it onto your website to get
paid for your hard work without having
to rely on ads paywalls and the misuse
of personal data as well as how to
receive payments securely for your
implementation we will do this with a
step-by-step tutorial that will show a
payment option for those visits in your
website or show exclusive content if
they already have a wallet enabled my
name is Anya Kubo and I'm a software
developer as well as course creator
online and your Guide to the wonderful
world of web monetization
this course was made possible today by a
grant from the web a fund that is
boosting open fair and inclusive
standards and innovation in web
monetization now what is web
monetization as mentioned in simple
terms web monetization means that you
can get money for every person that
visits your website but before I show
you how to do this in a way that does
not involve advertisers or monetizing
users data let's look at all the current
options available first
Amazon now there have been several ways
of gaining revenue from a website that
you built we have pay-per-click or PPC
adverts implemented onto a website or
cost per impression advertising also
done by implementing ads onto our
website
both of these would involve some kind of
advertisement that is paid for usually
by an advertising Network working on
behalf of a company
you have most likely seen the
pay-per-click advertising approach being
used on Google such as this company
right here okay so this company is
probably paying an advertising Network
such as Google ads to display an
advertisement with hyperlinks to their
website to increase traffic and
awareness in this example the company's
payment will go towards making sure that
company shows up at the top of the
search results
next we have cost for impression
advertising cost per impression
advertising works in the same way but
instead of paying full clicks you get
charged for how many people see your
advert in this situation the service of
increasing your brand awareness is being
monetized
in addition to these two forms of web
monetization we also have ad Banner
types affiliate programs and data
monetization Banner ad types include
having a visual displayed onto your
website that a company has directly paid
for or advertising agencies or networks
have paid for on their behalf
affiliate programs usually involve you
as the website owner receiving a
commission for every time someone
purchases a product or service from a
business if they came directly from your
website so for example if on my website
I had a link for some hot tubs and
someone clicked on the link and it takes
them to Amazon and they purchased a
wonderful hot tub from there I will
receive a commission payment of the sale
from Amazon and then we have data
monetization as a website owner you can
sell user data to companies for example
if you have a website that provides dog
grooming services for example you could
potentially collect data on what
demographics centered by your services
the most and at what time of year and so
on this behavioral data can be sold to
advertisers to better understand their
target markets and improve their own
online marketing campaigns now these are
all great and stuff but there is also a
way to make money from your website
without having to rely on any
third-party advertisers or selling any
user data this involves users who
appreciate your hard work and the
service you offer from your website
paying you a very very small payment so
for example a fraction of a cent for
visiting your sites
this way removes any need for a
middleman and allows the user to
preserve their privacy in return
to show you this in practice we are
going to build a website we will have a
free experience one with the
understanding that the user is paying to
use your site in return for being shown
ads and when are the premium experience
in which the user has enabled web
monetization so the adverts are removed
and perhaps we can even show them some
exclusive content while we're at it the
website will allow us to collect tiny
payments from the user if they wish to
view our site with the exclusive content
while maintaining their user privacy by
this I mean we must not allow for the
tracking of the user based on the
payments they make and it must not be
possible to get the details of the user
browsing history or anything like that
great another thing we can Implement is
this cool little counter that will show
exactly how much a user is contributing
to your website's Mission the website
will allow us to collect tidy payments
from the user if they wish to view our
site with the exclusive content while
maintaining their privacy by this I mean
we must not allow for the tracking of
the user base on the payments they make
and it must not be possible to get the
details of the user's browsing history
or anything like that
great
so let's get to it let's look at the
flow overview first
so the first thing we need to know is
that for the user who is visiting our
website to be able to use the web
monetization option they will need to
have an account with a web monetization
provider this is also known as a web
monetization sender easy right they must
also have a web monetization agent
installed on their browser the web
monetization agent is what is in charge
of initializing payments from the web
monetization provider on the user's
behalf
and the third part of the puzzle is the
web monetization receiver this is the
part that will take the payments from
the user to view the content on your
website
the web monetization receiver and the
web monetization provider do not need a
direct relationship their shared use of
the inter-ledger network allows payments
to be sent from the web monetization
provider to the web monetization
receiver
here is a super detailed look at the
flow of how this all works
so in a nutshell at point one the
website which has to have a meta tag
containing a payment pointer and uses
the browser to pass the tag to determine
where to send payments at Point 2 the
browser uses its internal web
monetization agent to calculate an
appropriate rate of payments to make to
the site
at Point 3 the browser generates a
unique session ID for this payment
session at point 4 the browser fetches a
unique destination address and shared
secret for the session from the site's
payment pointer URL
at 0.5 a payment receipt verifier
service proxies the request and sends a
receipt secret to generate receipts and
receipt nuns to include in those
receipts to the receiver
at 0.6 with the site's page still in
Focus the browser begins initiating
payments to the website at the
calculated rate from the user's web
monetization provider at point 7 the web
modernization provider sends the payment
to the web monetization receiver
at point eight the web monetization
receiver generates and sends a receipt
to the web monetization provider and at
point nine the web monetization provider
notifies the browser of successful
payments and at point 10 the browser in
turn dispatches an event that informs
the page of the payment and finally at
Point 11 the page confirms payment by
sending the receipt to the verified
service
easy
so now that we have covered the flow
let's do a deep dive into the two terms
that web monetization relies on and that
is interledger and payment pointers so
what is intelligent protocol now because
the payments that we are dealing with
are so so incredibly small individually
this is a problem for us as not many
payment clearing tools will work with
them this is where intelligent protocol
comes in the term intellectual refers to
a payment messaging protocol for making
payments of any size in the case of the
payments being very tiny it allows us to
aggregate them all and settle them over
existing payment Networks the web
monetization providers and web
monetization receivers use this protocol
to exchange payments they could be
directly connected or might connect via
one or more intermediaries
and what are payment pointers well in a
nutshell payment pointers are a really
neat way to pay an account in the same
way an email address provides an
identifier for a mailbox in the email
ecosystem a payment pointer is used by
an account holder to share the details
of their account with a counter party
it is essentially a URL that allows us
to find a user's account so for example
here would be my payment pointer and
here is an example of how I could
potentially get sent a payment
using payment pointers allows us to use
account identifiers that are safe to
share around unlike credit card numbers
for example
our site will include a URL similar to
this for us to get paid by inserting it
into an appropriate pack okay so with
all that knowledge I think it's time for
us to start creating our website so
let's do it
so first off we're going to sign up to
uphold which will be a way for us to
essentially get our payment pointer to
receive payments for everyone who visits
our website so just go ahead and sign up
I'm going to do it here with you just
use your email address and then select a
password so this is just a password I am
selecting a lot of my information will
be kept private so in the sign up
process there will be a lot of stuff
that is blurred out but just go ahead
and fill out exactly where you live
and then as well as your citizenship
from a drop down and once you have
selected that please go ahead and click
next
uh not forgetting to accept the terms
now on the next page it's just going to
ask you for your legal name and your
date of birth make sure that matches up
with your document ID that you'll be
using for the kyc section and just
certify that your name and date of birth
match your document that you will be
using
next you're going to put in a phone
number so that you can be contacted by
this phone number and hit next
to your phone number you will now
receive a verification code once you
receive that code just go ahead and put
that in and hit next once again just
verify your phone number once more and
fill in your home address so just tell
the uphold team where you live and hit
next
once that is done you're going to have
to go into your email and just verify
what we have done so just find the email
you might have to check your spam and
confirm everything is correct once that
is verified you should be taken to this
page that will allow us to essentially
do the kyc section so we're going to
start the verification process this will
bring up this modal in which you're
going to have to scan the QR code scan
the QR code and then you'll be asked to
scan your document so I'm going to use
my passport to do this just do the
process and once that is done you will
be verified again and once the process
is done just click continue
wonderful
so that should be done if this is taking
too long just refresh the page like I
did
and great you should now be on the
dashboard so now the first thing that we
are going to do is get our payment
provider so that's the URL that I was
talking about so just under here on the
from section I want you just to scroll
down so show more and we're going to
find the inter-ledger option so keep
scrolling and just select interledger
okay just like so and then that should
bring up your payment pointer so this is
what we're going to need please copy
that and great that's all we really need
from here now the code editor I'm going
to be using is webstorm so I'm just
going to bring up my code editor and I'm
going to create a project I'm going to
call this web monetization demo I'm
going to store it in my web storm
projects and I'm just going to create an
empty project
so if you're using vs code or anything
similar please go ahead and do that
process for that
now in my project I'm just going to
create an indexed HTML file so I'm going
to have to give it the HTML extension to
tell our code editor that this is an
HTML file and I'm just going to change
the title so it shows up our browser as
web monetization demo and don't forget
to hit save
okay now we're gonna have to add aim tag
in here that will allow us to feed in
our payment provider so just go ahead
and create a link tag and then as Rel
put monetization and for the href just
whack in your payment provider and
switch it up to be an URL by putting
https in front of it and that's really
it okay so step one done we have just
provided our payment provider so that we
can get paid for any time anyone visits
our web page
great
the next thing we're going to do is
actually sign up for coil this is the
payment sender that will essentially
allow us to choose to monetize a website
or not so just go ahead and in the
Chrome extensions so bring up your
browser I'm just going to paste in the
URL for this Chrome extension so that is
the URL you can of course go to the
Chrome Web Store and search for it it is
the coil extension okay this is how
we're going to stream micropayments to
our uphold account if someone visits our
website okay so this is what it looks
like
it does not track any browsing history
okay it's going to respect our users
privacy so please go ahead and add this
extension to your browser and just wait
for that to install
wonderful
so that has now been installed we're
just gonna have to sign up to our
account so once again just put in your
preferred email of choice so I'm going
to put in Anya at freecogram.org and I'm
just going to select a password
once that is done I'm just going to
agree to the terms of service and hit
next
so wonderful once again we're gonna have
to verify this so please head over to
your email address check your spam and
just put in the verification code into
the browser so there we go next we're
actually going to have to pay for this
so it's five dollars a month so I'm just
going to put in my credit card details
I'm going to put in my name on my credit
card
as well as my credit card details and
just start my coil membership for five
dollars a month
wonderful so once we select that button
we should be able to see the coil
extension
okay so that is all done now let's go
ahead and open up this page in our
browsers so I'm going to show you what
this looks like at the moment we do need
to actually put this on something that
is hosted online so in other words we
need a HTTP address for this to work but
don't worry I'm going to show you how to
do that next
so just to show you I'm just going to
open up this Pages document in our
browsers so as I'm using webstorm I
could just go ahead and click this
chrome little button right here and that
should bring up our website or if you're
using something like vs code we need to
get the absolute path so I'm going to go
ahead and copy the absolute path and
then just paste it into the browser like
so
okay
so wonderful I'm just going to go ahead
and inspect the page as well for later
use
now in our extensions
just make sure that the coil extension
is showing so you can pin it to the top
you will see that if we click on it
streaming is not enabled this is because
our site is not live it's not hosted on
the internet we're gonna have to do this
and I'm going to use hostinger to do
this okay please feel free to use
whatever hosting platform you wish
so just head over to hostinger and once
again we're just going to have to sign
up so that we can buy a domain and we
can host our files on that domain so
I've already got an account for this so
I'm just going to sign in to my hosting
or account this should show up my
dashboard that looks like this now let's
go ahead and purchase a domain so I'm
gonna go ahead and just select a domain
that is relatively cheap for demo
purposes so let's go ahead and find a
domain I'm going to choose
anyocubo.online as it's just 99 cents a
year and I'm just going to select to buy
it okay so I'm just going to choose one
year and I'm going to choose a payment
method and on this occasion I'm going to
choose PayPal once again please feel
free to use whatever payment choice you
wish
so once that's doing its thing we have
officially purchased our domain
okay
now we're going to have to just register
our domain so once again I'm going to
choose a country and I'm going to say
this is a personal account I'm just
going to fill in my contact details once
again so once again I'm blaring this out
from my own privacy
wonderful so that is now it our domain
is pending verification this is looking
great
once again just check your email to
verify this is all good now we're going
to have to host our files so we're going
to go to the hosting tab I'm just going
to select this first option and I'm just
going to once again choose the cheapest
option so the shared hosting single plan
for one month
and all I'm going to do is just select
pay now and great
so there we go and now let's fill out
these setup pages so I'm just going to
go ahead and click Start now I'm going
to say I'm creating this website for
myself I'm going to say other because
you know this is a demo so I'm just
going to select the other option and
then I'm going to go ahead and build my
website so select the builder website
and I'm just going to skip this part
and I'm going to select the domain of
Ania Cuba online okay and finish this
setup
great so we can view our website on a
preview at the moment because it's still
not finished doing its thing so this is
what it looks like as a preview okay but
of course we want to actually view the
actual website and for this the
activation process could take up to 48
hours so you might have to wait here so
please go ahead and take a break take a
breather and come back to this when your
website is finished
now once your domain is active let's
carry on with adding some code to our
document that we can host online so
let's do it the first thing I'm going to
do is just build out my web page before
actually implementing anything that
controls if the monetization is on or
off so let's go ahead and do the HTML
and CSS Port first just to spin up a
photo blog quickly
the first thing we'll do is just going
to add a header as well as a div that's
going to hold our section as well as our
hairline element
so here is our header and then I'm also
just going to create a div
I'm going to give this the class name of
article container so class
article
container and this is going to hold all
our articles as well as the section as
well as the hairline element
so let's go ahead and perhaps add the
hairline element in here and then the
section which is going to hold all our
articles now usually I would inject all
these articles in with JavaScript
however as a beginner tutorial I'm just
going to stick to building this out and
HTML and CSS
which means that in our section we are
going to have articles so here is what
each article is going to look like here
is the article element and in it I'm
going to put an issue tag which is going
to hold the heading to our article
as well as an image which is going to be
of a place that I have visited so I'm
going to give the source which is going
to be an image hosted online as well as
the alternative text
and then I'm just going to have a
paragraph tag explaining what the image
is about
okay so we're going to have six of these
so I'm just going to copy this
and put in six
two three four five six
okay great
now in the header well of course we need
a uh title and maybe a little bit of
description so I'm going to make a div
and I'm gonna give this the class name
of
title info so we can pick it out in our
CSS and in here I'm just going to put an
H1 tag that says welcome
to my photo
blog
just like so
and as well as a P tag that's going to
say use monetization
in order to see hidden content so really
trying to get people to use that
monetization on my website in order to
see some hidden exclusive content
above here I'm also going to create a
div
that's going to hold more information
I'm going to give it the class of info
container
and in our info container we're going to
have a div that's going to hold our logo
so I'm going to say class
logo
container
and in here instead of having a logo I'm
just going to put a symbol off the
internet one that I've found but of
course if you want to switch this out
for a logo then please go ahead and do
that
and along with our div of a logo
container I'm going to have another div
and this is going to be a div which I'm
going to give the class of currently
not
monetized
and if our site is monetized I'm going
to change out this class name okay to be
monetized we're going to apply different
styling to it I'm also going to give
this the ID of monetization
info so we can pick it out and change
the inner text so at the moment I'm
going to put not monetized okay and
again we're going to change that
dynamically based on if our site or in
other words someone that's viewing our
site with monetization on we'll see
monetized instead of not monetized okay
great
so wonderful perhaps let's get to
styling this up a little bit before
carrying on so to do this I of course
need to add a link tag in here and then
add Rel
style sheet and also link my style sheet
so let's go ahead and make a style sheet
so in my web monetization demo
repository I'm just going to create a
new file this is going to be a CSS file
I'm going to call it
dials
and just put CSS as the extension so our
code editors know to treat this as a CSS
file
wonderful
so I'm just going to minimize this and
perhaps put this on the right so we can
see both things
now I'm just going to link up this file
so as it's in the root of my project I
could literally just put the file name
we don't need to go into any other
folders it's just in the same place as
our index HTML file
so first off what I'm going to do is
actually style the uh body
to have
margin zero
and padding zero so we don't have any
weird borders happening around the body
of our document
and then I'm also going to say that
everything so all elements on my
document are going to have the font
family
now I've picked this out earlier it's a
font called
hinned
silly
Curry and as a default I'm going to have
Sans serif in case browsers are not
compatible with this font and you can
import it from Google fonts and you can
do so with the at import and then we're
going to use a URL
so please go ahead and copy this URL
it's going to go to the Google fonts uh
online API
so let's go ahead and type fonts
Google apis.com and then we're going to
just put in this link so css2 and then
the font family is family
hinned plus silly
Glory I'm going to import these
different font weights so wait
at 300
400
600 700
and display
equals swap okay making sure to put a
semicolon at the end so if you want to
read that out here is the full URL to
get that font
wonderful
so once we've done that I'm just going
to go ahead and pick out the header so
once again the header holds this div
which is the info container that has our
logo and monetized div which will tell
us that the site is being monetized from
the browser or not as well as the title
info so our header well I actually want
our header to have a background color of
this color that I have pre-chosen so
it's kind of a light light Coral okay
there you go it's extremely light and
I'm just gonna say the width should be
100 at all times making sure to spell
width correctly
great
so if we look at this in the browser so
once again if you're using webstorm I
would suggest just clicking on here to
bring that up and it will be hosted on
localhost
63342 however if you are using vs code
or anything other than webstorm that
doesn't have this kind of feature then
just go ahead and get this URL so get
the
part absolute part of the index HTML
file where it's stored locally so we're
going to copy the path copy the absolute
path
and just whack it in here
so this is what your website looks like
right now as a default it says not
monetize of course we know that this
will change dynamically we've just
hard-coded this for now so just bear
with me until we get into the JavaScript
section for this to change
okay so let's carry on
so now that we have done that I actually
want to be able to send her a few things
so I'm actually gonna get the header
again and say that any element with the
class of title info that lives inside of
this is going to have the height of 400
pixels
text align is going to be Center and
then I'm going to use display
Flex to make sure that it's centered
horizontally in that 400 pixel height so
display Flex Flex direction is going to
have to be column so that the two
elements the H1 element and the P
element stack over each other so let's
go ahead and put column and then we're
going to do justify content
Center
okay so just to show you what this
currently looks like I'm just going to
go back on the browser hit refresh and
great
so this is looking good let's Now work
on this info container
so let's go back to webstorm
I'm just going to minimize this a little
bit
this time we're going to pick out the
info container
so let's go ahead and do that so I'm
just going to
once again say that anything that lives
inside of the header that has the class
of info container well I want this to be
with 100 percent
and I'm also going to say that anything
that lives inside the header inside the
info container that has the ID of
monetization info
it's going to have the text color of
this lighter color
so this kind of off white color I'm
going to give it a padding of 10 pixels
I'm also going to give it a border
radius so it's rounded off
so 10 pixels a width of 140 pixels a
margin
of
20 pixels
and I'm going to make sure that the text
is centered now that will style this div
however I haven't given a background
color because I want to essentially
change the background color based on the
class so if it's not monetized I want
the background color to be this kind of
reddish color so once again I'm just
going to use the hex color for this and
I'm going to use this color that I have
pre-chosen so here we go
and then if we look in this in the
browser
that is what it looks like we can also
add a class for when it is monetized
so let's go ahead and maybe do that now
so if the class is monetized and
monetized you won't see this now well I
can show you manually so maybe I'll do
that then I'm going to give this a
slightly greenish color 73 c982
okay so now if I change this to be
monetized again we will be doing this
with JavaScript we'll be changing that
dynamically you will see that this is
green
so great again we will be doing that
later so let's put this back to not to
monetize and maybe let's make this a
tiny bit darker as it's a little bit
hard to read so there we go
wonderful and now let's also get the
logo container and just give it some
padding so I'm going to get the logo
container and give it a padding
Zero from the top 20 pixels from each
site
so once again I'm just going to show you
what this looks like so that you're
confident with each step
refresh so that is given a padding from
this top it's nothing but from the sides
it's 20 pixels and now I just want to
make sure that these two things are
spaced evenly and not stacked on top of
each other so we're going to use display
Flex on the info container where they
both live
so I'm just going to add display
Flex
and justify content space between
so once again
refresh
and great so we've done the header now
now let's get to styling the Articles so
this is great because we don't need to
style each individual article if you're
familiar with CSS then of course you
know we could just pick out the elements
then we can style them in all the same
styling will be applied
so let's go ahead and do that I'm going
to pick out the article
I'm going to say that each article is
going to have a border radius
of 10 pixels and then the Box
shadow
of a transparent color so RGB a and I'm
going to just make it an off black
with 0.2 percent opacity and then I'm
just going to say that we want it to be
zero pixels horizontally two pixels
vertically eight pixels blur and zero
spread
great and now I'm going to give it a
padding as well so 10 pixels I'm going
to say I want it to be display Flex so
that everything is stacked on top of
each other that we put into it so I'm
going to do Flex Direction uh column for
that so if you don't know flexbox
flexbox essentially uh displayflex
allows us to use this Command right here
and it's great for making websites a bit
more responsive I'm also going to say
that each
article should have a Max width of 400
pixels
and let's give it a margin to space them
out from each other
and also let's make sure the text in
these is kind of like a dark gray so I'm
going to just use once again a color
that I have previously found
great
now any image that lives inside the
Articles any image element inside the
article element is going to have a width
of a hundred percent
and now just to make sure that the
section will display them properly
because at the moment if we look in the
browser hit refresh you will see the
kind of stacking all over each other we
want them to appear to be in a row but
then also stack so sort of like a snake
if we can't fit them in the first line
so we're going to use flexbox for this
again
so we're gonna do this on the section so
I'm going to grab this section
I'm going to use display
Flex
and then I'm just going to do Flex
wrap wrap and I'm just going to justify
the content so the space around
each one
great and I'm also just going to give
some bottom margin to the hairline
elements so margin
bottom
40 pixels
okay so now if we look in the browser
you will see them all on a row but if we
start putting information in here you'll
see them snaking over each other
so let's go ahead and do that
so I'm just going to get rid of this for
now I've already kind of found a lot of
information that we can use so please
feel free to take my information if you
wish for the first heading we're going
to have wine Bay Australia and I'm just
going to link to an image on unsplash so
unsplash will allow you to use images
as long as you credit them so there is
one right here please credit this in
your projects if you use them of course
this is just for demo purposes so I'm
just going to leave that part out for
now
so there is the URL okay please feel
free to go to unsplash I'm going to show
you how to do this now
so unsplash
and then if you just go to any image so
for example if I want to choose this
image and then right click it and copy
the image address okay so this is
literally the image address that we are
taking apart from mine is of course not
of some plants it is of wine glass Bay
Australia so I search for that image on
unsplash and I used it in my project
I will be sharing the code for this in
the description below so if you want to
take my images then please go ahead so
I'm just going to put a photo of wine
Bay Australia
wine glass base sorry wine glass Bay
Australia and in the paragraph tag once
again I'm just going to paste in a
paragraph that I have taken from online
so there we go
now in here I'm actually going to make
an article that has some hidden content
so there is my H2 element so it's a
giveaway for my little readers and I
only want us to show if it's monetized
so I'm going to have to pick this out
which is why I'm going to give this an
idea of exclusive this is exclusive
content that we can only view if we're
viewing it in a browser that is allowing
monetization and I'm also going to give
it this class of hidden so we can apply
it and hide this okay if the
monetization is not on
so the sauce for this well I'm just
going to once again
put in a photo this time of the Grand
Canyon
so just put that in here and under alt a
photo of the grand
Canyon
and in the paragraph tags
is going to paste that in like so so I'm
just going to carry on doing this uh
please feel free once again to code
along and just use this information and
get the URL off me or feel free to use
your own I think that might be quite fun
you know you can really go to town and
what kind of images you use and so on
so photo
of the village of brain
and once again I'm just going to paste
in a paragraph about the village of rain
so there we go
I'm just gonna get one of Singapore
so once again just put that in the h2
tag put in an image that I have found
online or more specifically on unsplash
you don't have to go to unsplash you can
do any kind of image as long as you
credit it correctly if it's not yours
and that is required
a photo of the mer lion
and then I'm just going to paste in a
paragraph again
and just two more this time I'm going to
use a picture from Thailand it's going
to be of long tail alley
put in the image
put in some alt text photo of
boats
put in some paragraph texts and the last
one is going to be of Seoul in South
Korea a place that I really want to
visit maybe I should make that a
priority for this year
and once again just an image
some alt text
streets of soul
and a paragraph
so now let's check out what we have done
so if I go in here and I refresh the
page
there we go so this is looking cool this
is my photo blog so far so this is
looking good
so at the moment we can see there's like
everything is essentially not correct
right because currently web monetization
should not be allowed because we're just
doing our local files so this means that
we should not see the exclusive content
so for this I'm gonna have to do some
JavaScript so to do this well we're
gonna have to link up our Javascript
file and make one so I'm going to use
this script tag to do this and as the
source I'm just going to put app JS and
I'm going to create an app.js file
so in here I'm going to make a new file
called app.js
and in here we're going to put in our
you guessed it our JavaScript
so what I'm going to say is if
monetization is true essentially well if
it's true then we want to unhide so at
the moment let's actually make this
hidden as default so let's make sure
that this is hidden so let's apply the
class of hidden to this but we actually
have to make it two so I'm going to go
dot hidden
display
none
okay so now if you look in the browser
as a default or exclusive div and in
fact I'm also going to give this maybe
so I'm going to actually also just so
it's really obvious get exclusive
and give it the background color of like
a red so that we know that
when it's being visible and when it
isn't being visible so in the browser
as a default this should be hidden so if
I refresh it's hidden okay so that is
good
so now we're going to use JavaScript to
check if web monetization is on and if
it is show that exclusive content
so before we do anything at all let's
just check that our web monetization
works
so all I am going to do is essentially
pick out I'm going to pick out the link
element that we just added with our
payment pointer that we converted into a
URL so let's go ahead and get the
document object from the HTML Dom API
and then I'm going to use the query
selector to look for the link so the
element of Link in our HTML by the Rel
monetization right because we have two
links we have one for our style sheet
and we have the one we added for our
monetization making sure to spell that
correctly so monetization that looks
good to me now I'm going to save this as
something so we can work with it easier
now I'm going to grab the link and use
the add event listener method to listen
out for an event that event is
monetization and if monetization is on
well then we need to execute the
following code okay so that is how the
ad event listener works it works on an
object and we listen out for this event
on the object so if monetization is on
then we execute this code
so this is essentially a callback
function and in here for now I'm just
going to say yay monetization is on
and save so that's all I'm going to do
now if we look at this in our browser
let's just go ahead and get rid of this
for now
you will see not much has changed okay
and even if I inspect the page and look
at the console log we won't see that
console okay our monetization is not on
but why is this we've done all the steps
right however streaming is not enabled
so this is because we actually used to
host these files on the internet so
let's go back to our hostinger just make
sure that 24 hour hold has been lifted
okay so you shouldn't see any Banner
here anymore and I'm just going to
scroll down
to file manager
and then that will redirect me to the
files on Anya Dash kubo.com as you will
see here you'll see public underscore
HTML
now you might have a default PHP file in
here please feel free to get rid of it
if you do or you might not I don't have
it so I have nothing to remove
and all I'm going to do is just drag in
those three files that I have made so go
ahead and find them in your web
monetization demo directory on your
computer and then just go ahead and drag
them in like so
okay
great that was pretty easy
so now if I go back here we can shut
that down now
and just copy the mid domain and then go
ahead and paste it in your browser
and inspect the page making sure that
the coil extension is on it should say
thank you this time you call membership
streams payments to the site while
you're on it and if we look in the
console log
you will see yay monetization is on
wonderful okay so we now know that
monetization is on this is saying that
our payments are streaming everything is
looking good
next up I actually want to change stuff
visually based on if our monetization is
on okay so once again your monetization
will be on once you host the files
online it will not be on when you're
just viewing your files online like so
okay and another thing that has to be on
is the coil extension and you have to be
able to see this visual rather than
this visual
okay
great one final thing before we move on
it would seem that our CSS is responding
with an error to the font that I have
imported so let's go ahead and fix that
it would seem there should be an and
rather than an at
and great so that has been applied
and let's move on
so now that we have that working and we
know how to host our files online in
order to get monetization going let's
carry on next up I'm actually going to
pick out the button
so I'm going to pick out
this button right here by the ID
so let's go ahead and get that I'm just
going to copy this and it might app.js
file making sure that I am still in here
in between these curly braces right as
we want it to be when web monetization
is on so we're listening out for web
monetization I am going to look in my
document I'm going to use get element by
ID this time to search for an ID
of monetization info let's just go ahead
and make all of this consistent with
double quotes everywhere and now that
I've got that button I'm going to just
save it as something and I'm going to
save as const monetization
display as it's technically more of a
display than a button because we can't
really click on it
then
I'm going to grab that display and I'm
going to use text content actually
change the content inside of it to say
monetize this time mono ties okay so we
know that it's monetized if monetization
is on if we can listen up for
monetization
so that's what we're doing we're going
to change it to say monetized and I also
want to change its color which means
that I'm going to have to get it again
so get the monetization display and this
time I'm going to use class list add to
add the monetized class okay
so as a reminder the monetize class is
one that we wrote here so it's this
green color right here and not monetized
is this red color so that's what I'm
adding and I'm also actually going to
remove the red one so the red color by
getting monetization display class list
remove
not
come on then
ties
wonderful
so shall we see what this looks like so
far let's do it so at this time actually
just going to copy all of this and let's
go back to hostinger
so here we are and then scroll back to
where I have uploaded my files
so just here
click back into the public go back into
the app.js file and I'm just going to
replace that code and save this so this
little green tick should show up to
notify us that this page is saved and
while we're here I'm actually going to
go back to the style sheet as well and
just replace this first line
so I'm going to grab
the correct import URL
and then just
replace it here
great and of course don't forget to save
that file
great and once that's saved let's go
back to
still Sid website
so and
Kubo online and this might work or it
might not we might have to actually
clear some cookies and caches so it does
seem I have to do this please go ahead
and click on here go to more tools
and clear your browsing data
and just clear the data for the last 24
hours and then just go back to your site
okay and refresh
and great as our site is monetized
you'll see it is monetized this display
is now green wonderful now if yours
isn't just make sure that your code is
the same you could check it by going on
the elements and just checking that your
head has the correct link and that your
app.js file has the correct code okay so
go into sources and check under object s
and it should be the code that we just
written most recently
right
cool this is what it should look like in
full
so that is just a good way to check if
the latest code is what you are viewing
so wonderful that is how you would
change elements based on if something is
monetized or not
next up I'm going to show you how to
show exclusive content if your site is
monetized so let's do it
so what I'm going to do is just go back
in here
because this time we're going to pick
out we're going to pick out
the exclusive article that we wrote so
this article right here with the idea of
exclusive so let's go ahead and pick it
out making sure that once again you are
in these Kylie braces like so
and all I'm going to do this time is
look in the document and get element by
ID again well we know that this ID is
exclusive because we just looked at it
and all I'm going to do is use class
list remove and I'm going to remove the
hidden class that we wrote previously
okay because if monetization is on we
want to remove the class of hidden that
we wrote Because the class of hidden is
what's preventing us from seeing that
article correct because if we look here
we have added display none to the whole
article so we can't see it and if the
monetization is on WE essentially want
to remove this so that we can see the
article once again
so let's check it out this time I'm
simply going to grab this one line of
code let's go back to our host singer
and in the app.js file I'm just simply
going to add that line of code like so
we can probably get rid of this console
log now too you really don't need it
so great make sure that file is saved by
that tick showing up in the corner you
know that this is file is saved I'm
simply pressing command s to do so or
you can click on this icon right here it
will do the same thing
great and now let's go back to our
hosted files
and once again if I refresh this
you will see that code is not updating
we still see the console log we don't
see the other line so once again I'm
just going to clear everything so go to
more tools
clear browsing data
delete everything from the last 24 hours
get rid of that
and now if I refresh this
amazing we will see the latest code
showing up and we will also see the
exclusive article because web
monetization is on this is opposed to
when it's not on and we can't see that
article we can't see the article in red
got it
great
so that is how you would show exclusive
content to people with web monetization
wonderful
next up I'm going to show you how to
actually display the amount people are
donating to your course or your website
by having web monetization on we're
going to do so by adding another P tag
to the header and displaying the amount
as well as the currency that we are
working in
so let's do it let's go back to our web
store
so once again making sure we are in the
curly braces let's add some code I'm
just going to get rid of the console log
so it's consistent with what we have
uploaded onto the internet
and great
so this time what I'm going to have to
do is pass through an event okay I've
passed through an event because this
event object actually has a lot of stuff
that we can use in order to show us the
amount that we are gaining from web
monetization as well as the asset code
and acid scale we will go into what
these are in more detail in a bit
first off however I'm going to show you
how to de-structure some data from the
event object so if we go ahead and grab
the event object some things in that
object are the amount that we have
gained the asset code
and the asset
scale
okay
so just go ahead and destructure those
things like that
the amount as I said is an integer
amount delivered by an ILP packet the
asset code is essentially a string
representing the currency code so for
example if we're working in dollars you
would get USD and if you're working in
Euros you would get EUR and so on and
the asset scale is the scale of the
received amount
what I mean by this is that it defines
how small the units of amount will be on
this panel pointer a bigger scale means
smaller units if your scale is 2 and
your asset code is USD then it means you
will need 100 units to get one dollar
I'm going to show you this in code
okay so we're going to need all three of
these so essentially built a
micropayment counter let's do it
so fast off we're going to have to
actually start off with a total so total
is going to start off with being zero so
when we load our page our total is zero
meaning that we can save the asset code
once and only once and that it doesn't
keep getting reassigned over and over
again because that is pretty much
constant that's not going to change
right the amount however will change it
will essentially grow incrementally so
if total equals zero which should be on
the very first load of this document
then we're going to get the asset scale
and assign it to
the scale up here okay at the moment
this is going to be
just going to leave it as null
and I'm going to then assign asset scale
to it up here so that it's saved once
and we don't have to touch it again
okay
great and of course we need to display
this in the browser so I'm going to
actually have to create some elements
for this so I'm going to do it by ID I'm
just going to go back in here and scroll
up we did say we want to just create a
another paragraph tag for this so let's
go ahead and do that
with your help
you have supported me by and I'm going
to use the spam tag to break this up
and then in here I'm going to put the
total amount I'm going to hard code this
as zero to start with and then I'm going
to give this the ID of total
and then another span tag to actually
put in the asset code so let's go ahead
and perhaps
put currency in here for now so when
this loads the first time it will say
with your help you have supported me by
zero
okay and then of course when the
monetization is on then we should
populate this with the asset code in
this case it's going to be US Dollars
and this total will be overwritten with
the total that someone has supported you
with
so let's go ahead and do it let's pick
out this span element by its ID and the
ID is currency so I'm going to copy that
I'm going to look for the element with
the ID of currency and now I'm just
going to get its inner text
and assign asset code to it
okay so once again this will only really
happen once on the load of the document
and now we're going to have to actually
get that total which at the moment has a
value of zero and we're going to have to
essentially add to it so whatever tool
is we're going to get the amount I'm
going to keep adding to that total over
and over again every time that it's
updated and we just need to change it
into a number value otherwise this is
actually a string it comes back as a
string so we need it to be a number so
that we can add to it mathematically
great and once we have done that I'm
just going to format the total to a more
readable format for us by essentially
multiplying it to the scale so let's go
ahead and save this as formatted total
and I'm going to get the total whatever
the total is multiply it by math to the
power of 10 minus the scale
let's actually go ahead and perhaps
put this in parenthesis so it's more
readable and I'm going to do it to fixed
the scale
okay and now I'm going to look at my
document get element by ID and that ID
is total
so that's what we want to pick out and
this time again we're just going to use
inner text
to assign a new formatted total
great
so once again let's save this now
and actually I'm just going to try
put this all a little bit closer
together just like so so we can see all
of it
Okay so
that we go perhaps it's annotated a bit
so this was to
display
to user if monetization is on
this was to
show exclusive content to the user
if one entire station is on
and this
was to implement
micro payment counter
and display
it to our user so we've done three cool
things here with the web monetization
okay I just want to actually now show
you if this works so I'm just going to
this should be
triple equals sorry and what doesn't it
like about this formatted data formatted
data I think that should be fine
let's go ahead and copy all of this
and go back to
hostinger
okay so back in here I'm just going to
go in my app.js file and replace all of
that with this new code
okay so that is the code we want now and
save this
and then we also need to update our
index HTML to have that one new line
that we wrote which is this new
paragraph
I'm just going to put it down here
and once again hit save you can save
here as well and let's view this now
so refresh
as you will see that has not updated our
code so let's go ahead and clear some
browser data
clear data
and fresh
and great now you will see the amount
that a user is helping you out by by
viewing this with web monetization you
will see that value is growing
incrementally they are micro payments so
they are very small however it's pretty
cool to see exactly how much someone is
supporting you by by viewing your web
page
got it amazing
so thanks very much for watching I hope
this was useful I'm going to be sharing
the code with you in the description
below so please go ahead and take it and
just replace it with your own payment
pointer and that should work fine
thanks very much again and I'll see you
again soon